the president also said Republicans are
100% behind him on impeachment the House
Intelligence Committee plans to release
a key report today and it's expected to
show evidence against the president for
potential articles of impeachment Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill for us Nancy
good morning do we have an idea of what
this report will say sure so this report
is going to serve as the underpinning
for the Democrats impeachment case it
lays out the house intelligence
committees findings after two months of
hearings and depositions and Democrats
tell us that their chief finding is that
the president held up military aid to
Ukraine and a coveted White House
meeting while he and top officials
pressured Ukraine's president to
investigate campaign rival Joe Biden
yesterday House Republicans produced
their own 120 page report essentially a
pre Buttle of the Democrats case the GOP
report insists there was quote no direct
first-hand evidence that mr. Trump
improperly pressured the Ukrainian
president Tony and Nancy the House
Judiciary Committee is holding its first
public hearing and the inquiry tomorrow
what can we expect from that well the
committee has announced the four legal
scholars who will essentially lay out
the historical precedence for impeaching
a president three of them were invited
by the Democrats one chosen by the
Republicans all of them law professors
and longtime experts on constitutional
matters this hearing is going to take
place while the president is away in
London for this NATO summit the White
House was invited to participate in the
hearing its lawyers could have asked
questions but the White House rejected
that offer on Sunday calling it an
unfair process Antoni in London the
president was asked if all of this has
hurt his standing on the world stage he
said no but that he does think it has
been bad for the country all right Nancy
Cordes for us on Capitol Hill Nancy
thank you very much